hi guys I'm Rahul from simply lon and
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become a blockchain developer now before
we begin let's see the current situation
of the market 84% of companies are now
dabbling into blockchain blockchain is
the fastest-growing scale in the u.s.
freelance job market Apple Steve Wozniak
is getting involved with blockchain
projects and JP Morgan CIO believes the
blockchain will replace existing
technology as we can see the amount of
focus organizations are putting on
blockchain and what tech influences
around the world have to say about it
we can see clearly that they really
believe that blockchain can have a
tremendous positive impact on our lives
and the market as a whole so it's no
surprise that blockchain has worldwide
acclaim now it's created a huge number
of job opportunities across the world
and once a job is that of a blockchain
developer so here's what we're going to
learn today who is a blockchain
developer what are the types of
blockchain developers the steps you have
to follow to become a blockchain
developer the obstacles you might face
by learning blockchain the salary's
offered to blocks in developers and how
companies are using blockchain right now
so who is a blockchain developer a
blockchain developer is someone who
designs implements and supports a
blockchain network so in a way they are
responsible for setting up the block she
network and then ensuring that it works
properly we create and optimize
blockchain protocols for example is the
network a public network they create
such protocols and then optimize it
based on that usage or requirement they
develop distributed applications and
smart contracts on the blockchain
network now let's talk about the
different types of blockchain developers
so they follow the two major categories
core blockchain developers and
blockchain software developers a core
blockchain developer works on the core
features and the architecture of the
blockchain network basically they're in
charge of the entire blockchain network
they manage the architecture of the
network supervises the blockchain
network they work on consensus
algorithms for example there's the
proof-of-work algorithm in Bitcoin and
set of blockchain protocols a core
blockchain developer works very much
like a core web developer now the main
thing is that they both work on core
concepts now just like
option developers work on protocols you
have web developers working on protocols
like HTTP or tcp/ip and so on now let's
talk about a blockchain software
developer now they work on blockchain to
create applications now they create
smart contracts develop distributed
applications and work on the front and
back-end application development
blockchain software developers are also
very similar to web application
developers both of them create
applications on a network that's already
set up by core developers so how do you
become a blockchain developer so before
you start off on your path to becoming a
blockchain developer there are some
things that you really have to know now
we're going to talk about the
prerequisites first up you have
programming languages now it is
absolutely necessary that you be
well-versed in programming languages
before you can get onto blockchain
development most blockchains are created
in languages like Java C++ Java Script
goo Python c-sharp and so on so let me
emphasize how important it is that you
know programming languages now for core
blockchain development any of these
before-mentioned languages will do the
job for you however in case you have to
create distributed applications and
smart contracts on aetherium it is
mandatory that you learn the programming
language solidity then you need to
understand the fundamentals of
object-oriented programming now the
concepts of object-oriented programming
which anyone who codes will know is the
wrapping up of data and functions into a
single unit this is exactly what block
genes function on for example you have
the etherium block here it has two
components data and function the user
details act as the data now this data
includes the person who's sending the
transaction or how much money they're
planning to transfer then you have the
function which is the command to send
and receive payments then you need to
learn about flat and relational
databases now blockchain was created on
the basis of these two types of
databases a flat database stores data in
a single table structure and a
relational database uses a number of
tables and can cross-reference records
across tables so it is necessary that
you understand how these two databases
work to completely understand how
blockchain was created from their
concepts then you need to learn what
structures are you need to understand
the working of data structures like
stacked link list queue and so on this
is because blockchain by itself is a
backlink list each block in a blockchain
references the previous block now this
is done by a field in the blocks header
known as the previous hash that holds
the hash value of the preceding block
knowledge about web application
development by being well versed in web
app development you're opening yourself
to a wide range of opportunities to
create web and mobile applications using
blockchain technology because regardless
of whether the application works on
blockchain technology the front-end can
be created only with web application
development then you need to know about
networking block chains work on the
Internet so you need to understand the
many concepts regarding networks for
example how systems are able to
communicate with each other how the
network works and so much more
know after you're done with all of this
you're ready to start your journey to
become a blockchain developer the first
step is to understand the concepts of
blockchain now south-ossetia nakamoto's
whitepaper bit can't appear to peer
electronic caste system gives the detail
account on how Bitcoin works and
introduces us to the concept of
blockchain so if you want to learn
firsthand how blockchain works from the
creator of Bitcoin himself I would
suggest you go to Satoshi nakamoto's
paper next you need to learn important
terms related to blockchain for example
what is a minor what is a block what is
a public distributed ledger hash
encryption proof-of-work mining and so
much more then you can learn how systems
other than Bitcoin like it's helium
hyper ledger hash graph and so on
use blockchain to work with their
technology the second step in was
understanding the economics behind
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
blockchain technologies work on crypto
economics which is nothing but the
combination of two words cryptography
and economics cryptography and
blockchain involves hashing digital
signatures and proof of work hashing is
involved in maintaining the privacy of a
user within the network this is made
possible with the help of cryptography
algorithms for example in Bitcoin we
have the sha-256
and Edie hash in its helium digital
signatures help validate a particular
user within the network this is made
possible with the combination of the
users public and private keys proof of
work involves miners around the world
trying to solve a complex mathematical
puzzle to be able to add block to the
blockchain on the economic side you need
to understand how miners are
incentivized the users who add and take
part in the blockchain are given
cryptocurrencies now people who take
decisions also have the right to charge
a fee for the service for example if a
person has a block and he has to decide
what transactions he's going to add to
that block he has the right to charge
you some amount of money if you want
your transaction to be added to his
block good users of the network are
rewarded with monetary compensation or
the ability to take decisions bad users
of the network have to pay a fine or
have the rights to take decisions
stripped away step 3 is to understand
how cryptocurrencies work with
cryptocurrencies there's a whole number
of steps before a process is complete
you need to understand how each and
every step works for example first how
ascender begins the transaction to send
money to the receiver how the message is
encrypted and transmitted across the
network
how miners are able to verify that runs
action how the block is add to the
blockchain how money is deducted from
each of the participants wallets you
need to understand the relationship
between each and every step of the
process and how they interact with each
other
step 4 getting some hands-on experience
now after you're done with all the steps
that I mentioned before this one's the
hardest practical application so even if
you know all the theory if you don't
have any practical experience it won't
have a very large impact so you need to
start coding and creating your own smart
contracts you need to create your own
distributed applications on the etherium
platform also let me remind you for you
to be able to create smart contracts or
distributed applications you need to
have learnt the programming language
solidity and finally you can invest in
bitcoins or other cryptocurrencies so
that you can have an understanding of
how they actually work now it's very
important that you also keep yourself
updated to guard
cryptocurrencies and block chains and
bitcoins by reading up on blogs and
forums you can take part and discard
chat rooms you can use the telegram
application which has a very active
community on cryptocurrencies and
blockchain you can involve yourself in
subreddits like a slash blockchain a
slash Bitcoin and other related sub
reddits you can get on coin market cap
the talks about market capitalizations
of several cryptocurrencies coin market
cal and so much more as an abundance of
resources or the internet that you can
take advantage of now let's talk with
the obstacles that you might face while
learning blockchain now you've noticed
the blockchain isn't very easy there's a
lot of content to cover now to make
matters worse you could also face some
of these problems first of them is
outdated content now the tutorials and
content that you might find online
cannot possibly keep up with the
constantly changing technology so it's
only natural that the content that you
might get might be a little outdated
which isn't what you want you want the
latest and the most highest quality
content secondly lack of quality content
now there's an abundance of sources that
you can learn from and since there's
such a wide variety it's possible that
you might end up using a type of source
that's of low quality or of substandard
quality now let's talk about salaries
that you can get in a blockchain job now
in the United States blockchain
developers earn one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars per annum
according to burning last technologies
in the more tech oriented areas of us
like Silicon Valley in New York in
Boston they earn up to one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars per annum several
companies around the world have invested
heavily into incorporating blockchain
into their processes now you have
companies like alphabet pack of America
Wells Fargo Apple Microsoft and so on so
this is a clear indication that
companies are very interested in hiring
people who are skilled enough in the
concepts of blockchain and finally how
are companies using blockchain one what
uses blockchain to keep track of each
and every step in the supply chain with
this they're able to track down where
the problem area is and to ensure that
the problem is solved before it can
happen again
you have JP Morgan
Jason Cole this company created their
own blocks in application called quorum
that solves the processing that allows
private transactions to take place in a
group of participants whose identities
are known the Agricultural Bank of China
created a learning system using
blockchain that aim to help small and
medium sized agricultural businesses
that didn't have a good credit record
now how can simply learn help you simply
learn provide certification courses that
give you an introductory or an advanced
understanding into the concepts of
blockchain the introductory blockchain
basics course provides 12 hours of
self-paced learning and covers all the
concepts related to Bitcoin and
blockchain data structures moreover it
gives you an introduction into
blockchain Bitcoin blockchain mining
buying and selling bitcoins emerging
trends and blockchain and so much more
now the advanced course or the
blockchain certification training course
provides 32 hours of instructor-led
training 50 plus hands-on exercises
using blockchain technology 9 practical
projects covering aetherium hype ledger
and bitcoin case studies and so on it
also helps you understand solitaire
programming it's helium coding advanced
smart contracts helium application
architecture real life projects and so
much more the content of these courses
are constantly updated to keep up with
emerging trends in the market and it is
of highest quality with that we've
reached the end of another video I hope
you guys found this video informative
and helpful thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here